So let's begin with the AI controller.
A controller in Unreal Engine 4 is a non-physical actor
that can possess a pawn or derived actor
such as the character.
Built already into Unreal Engine 4,
we have several derived types of controllers
such as the one that we're discussing right now.
But it's worth mentioning the player control
at the very least.
The player controller can be best described
as the will of the player.
So we can surmise that the AI controller
is the simulated will of an AI agent.
All controllers, no matter what type,
share some common functionality and traits.
The first is that the control of a pawn
is done with the possess function
and it's relinquished with the calling
of the unpossessed function.
Controllers also have a one-to-one relationship
with a pawn, meaning a single pawn
can only have one controller,
which works perfectly for most AI.
Where the AI controller differs from the base controller
or any derived player controller,
is that it's exclusively created on the server
and it's never replicated to any clients
in a networked game.
This is important as AI must be authoritative
and in networked games, the server is that source of truth.
The AI controller houses four main components
that allow AI agents to function in our games.
The components being the behavior tree component
and this can be best described as the brain of the AI.
The blackboard component,
best described as the memory of the AI.
The perception component, and as the name suggests,
this derives what senses the AI has.
Followed by the path following component
and again, pretty self-explanatory.
This allows the AI to navigate the level.
Previously, triggering AI logic used to be done
either through Blueprint or through code
by starting the behavior tree when we possess the pawn.
However, the AI controller now exposes control
in Blueprint and Native C++ to allow the AI logic
to begin immediately when possessing the pawn.
The AI controller also implements
the generic team agent interface.
This interface implements functionality
that allows for querying what team and AI agent
may be on, as well as what their attitude
towards another actor might be.
Unreal implements a generic team identification system
straight out of the box, which is flexible
and completely up to the developer
to implement in whatever way they see fit.
Lastly, the AI controller provides programs
with a handy entry function to determine
how our AI agent selects the target that they focus on.
The actor's perception updated function
sends through an array of actors
they have perceived recently.
Once again, the implementation of this is left empty
to allow each developer to implement
their own target selection process.